so hello everyone welcome my name is
Evelyn sbobet and I'm a technologist at
thoughtworks I am super passionate about
social justice and technology have been
pursuing this initiative for six years
and I'm very humbled and grateful to be
here today just to share my story to say
where I come from and to speak on the
story of Ferguson and how you can get
involved so definitely thank you Alex
Miller and strange loop for having me
because to have an afro latina someone
who's black and Puerto Rican to be here
in to speaking to you and a woman is a
very powerful at a tech conference so
shout-out to y'all thank you before we
get started I wanted to fill the room
out by a quick survey so I have some
questions I'm going to ask if any of
these questions pertain to you and
there's a yes just raise your hand and
then after each question we'll put our
hands down cool with you dope so raise
your hand if you went to college whoa
that's a lot of pants I'll sit down
raise your hand if your parents went to
college raise your hand if you have ever
been harassed or targeted by the police
raise your hand if you had a computer in
your home growing up raise your hand if
you had ever had a champ raise your hand
if you ever had to change your birth
name to get a job raise your hand if you
know what tech activism is
raise your hand if you know where
Ferguson Missouri is thank you for
participating in that and these next
stories that i will share i'll provide
more context to those questions so to me
tech activism is the intersection where
technologists and community organizers
meets and they knowledge share and they
create tools and programs and solutions
to protect oppressed communities i was
inspired to talk to you today about tech
activism due to all the civil unrest
corner on around the world as you notice
there have been more protests organized
resistance and uprisings occurring in
response to increased brutality against
oppressed communities now more than ever
millions of people across demographics
and communities all over the world are
rising up together they're rising up to
resist exploitation they're rising up to
resist racism they're rising up to
resist state terrorism topics that will
discuss today include what is our role
as technologists in activism how is
technology both helping and hindering
the effectiveness of activism and more
importantly how do we hold each other in
this room how do we hold each other
accountable to bring our wisdom
knowledge and resources to the table to
really push the narrative and to push
the needle of social justice within our
communities as I share my personal story
of how I broke into the tech industry I
wanted to start off with the story of my
name many people know me as a be even on
my Twitter handler I use a bebo bay but
Abby's not money it's not my middle name
it has nothing to do with my name my
name is Eveline Eveline sbobet and as a
kid growing up a lot of my non-latino
teachers always had a problem saying my
name and many times I was humiliated and
embarrassed by this and I would always
go home and
so very frustrated that I got made fun
of again because people didn't know how
to say my name and oftentimes teachers
didn't even call on me because they were
embarrassed to say my name it was very
intimidating so my brother my older
brother created the name Abby he was
like it's a very amazing name very
friendly less intimidating everyone
loves a B and I definitely took on that
name and for my entire life I've been
using and going by a bee however when I
graduated college I wanted the
professional world to know me as
ethylene and i put on my cover letter in
my resumes ethylene sbobet and i said
everything out but i didn't get any
responses and it was weird because i was
very proud of my accomplishments and i
was like i should at least get a first
like phone interview something but then
i was thinking people have been
embarrassed and intimidated by by my
name so i wonder if that was the case so
i changed my name on my resume to a bebo
bay and add we received lots of
opportunities every receive phone calls
and interviews and just emo responses
and i received my job as a people bay so
I again took on the name as a people bay
but today as I stand before you as a 31
year old woman I want to use my name
Eveline Eveline is tied to my culture my
grandmother named me it connects me to
who I am to my mother but I understand
that some cultures and the times that we
live are more often valued than others
I'm from North Philly born a raise and
the playground is where I spent most of
my days anyone who's from Philly can
sing along and I carry the culture of my
family and my neighborhood everywhere I
go I'm very proud to have grown up in a
black and Puerto Rican Family I'm from
the neighborhood called badlands
and North Philadelphia it's in the zip
code 1913 319 133 is the pouring zip
code in Philadelphia where factories and
booming businesses once stood empty lots
and abandoned buildings boarded up
houses now occupy where I live these are
actually screen shots outside my
mother's house this is how my house and
my neighborhood looks right now and then
the last two years Philadelphia cloves
23 of its public schools I attended
public high school in Philadelphia I
attended a school named Thomas Edison
and we had a 75-percent dropout rate
this meant my freshman year kind of
looked just like this my freshman year
we started screwing there was 1200
students and they brought us to an
auditorium on day one and they told us
look to the left and look to the right
by tenth grade one of you won't be here
we graduated 287 students we had more
substitute teachers and actual teachers
we barely had textbooks and you were
forced to encounter and just be around
the police all the time in order to get
into the school you had to go to metal
detectors and he had to be patted down
and in my neighborhood the police were
always circling which was odd because
growing up we knew if you called the
police they wouldn't come to your
neighborhood to help you but you've seen
them in the streets and you were always
being harassed by them so it was really
interesting most students never even had
the opportunity to speak to a guidance
counselor so College was never in the
question of many of our students but
fortunately for me there was this pastor
his name was passed a movin Jenkins and
he attended it was a professor at
Indiana University of Pennsylvania IUP
it's near Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and he
would go into the inner cities of
Philadelphia
to the worst schools and pick about 30
students he saw potential in so student
like myself he pulled up my grades and
like a bee on paper you're like the
worst students but if someone looked at
you in a magnifying glass they would see
you were you were so passionate you're
so persistent he has so much
determination because I went to school I
had a job and I worked about like 30
hours a week I took care of my family I
helped my sisters and my brothers all
the time a lot of people my age didn't
even do as much as I did but on paper I
sucked i had about like a 50-percent
attendance rate and this program that he
would put us in was called the
philadelphia a partnership program and
in this program it gave students like me
a second chance to go to college the
program wouldn't look at your sh t
scores or your GPA which was awesome
because as a senior I'd even know what a
GPA was so I graduated was the first to
graduate and my family's to go beyond
middle school high school and then to
college my family which was quite an
accomplishment and I did terrible my
first year and it wasn't your typical
like oh I was partying in my freshman
year and got too drunk he's gonna go to
class but more was when I went to class
I didn't understand what the professor's
were saying it was like I was in Charlie
Brown's teachers class and she was just
like waa waa waa waa waa waa he was like
what the heck is this lady or man
singing and I wanted to drop out of
school so I called my mom and I was a
keno would like I did terrible i wanted
to drop out and i wanted to drop out not
because I couldn't just understand but
even when I went to the professors and
told them hey I'm having a hard time
understanding class by the time they
understood how far behind I was one of
my professors told me to drop out and go
to middle school and probably I would
have a chance at just learning what
we're going through in college I want to
study guide sessions with other students
and people were like you know
if you could not come to our study
sessions because you're very disruptive
because you're so far behind you keep us
behind so I told my mom I'm dropping out
I tried and she was like well what do
they have that you don't why are they
seceding and you're felling and I told
her I mean I go to school and then I
work and after work I come home late at
night and it's too late to walk to a
computer lab but other students if they
go into their rooms they have their
computers and laptops I didn't have one
so my mom was amazing and she
crowdfunded my first laptop which back
then was in cod crowdfunding it was like
knocking on people's doors and like hey
my daughter needs a laptop can you
donate and together with my relatives
they gave him my first laptop with my
first laptop it was like the whole world
was in my hands I had access to all
these YouTube tutorials I went to ask
jeeves a lot so like our keynote speaker
this morning was talking about I went to
actually nice and actually actually
helped me out because at times where I
was embarrassed to act things that I
didn't know i was actually zacks him
everything what is a plus B equals C and
without judgment I was able to get
tutorials and just learn and through
collective learning with online
contributors from freshman year not
knowing what a number line was I was
able to graduate with 3.75 and apply
statistics which I thought was pretty
dope
I ended up graduating college with a
marketing degree and apply statistics
really because I wanted to change the
stories and the content and the
narrative being fed and two people in my
community and to use in my high school
and I wanted to challenge the statistics
because honestly still to today where do
they serve a these people at they never
go to my hood and survey us so I've
always been interesting and challenging
the statistics that's out there about
black and puerto ricans when I graduated
college I had a full time offer at a
corporate job I was doing marketing
analysts at supervalu which is a food
retailer and I was working in the
greater philadelphia area i was making
more than my mom dad and grandmom
combined so it was very happy even
though it wasn't a lot with only making
50,000 to me it was like baller alert
and I was able to help my family with a
whole bunch of stuff not only that I was
a leader I was in the leadership
position in their diversity recruiting
and diversity events and I managed their
nonprofit and with their nonprofit we
were able to donate a million dollars to
the other nonprofits all around the
greater philadelphia area and i thought
this was amazing but after my third year
of doing it it felt like was pin passing
out band-aids to my community like oh
here's a band-aid about diversity and
although this nonprofit is struggling
with homelessness here's a thousand
dollars and it didn't feel right I was
thinking and reflecting in my life like
what happened in my life that changed my
trajectory and how can I bring that same
impact to other people's lives and to me
it was the power of a laptop so I went
on Google because then axj smart wasn't
a school and I went on Google and I was
like how do i get into the tech industry
and where is it and seriously
I found out through guru that the
technology industry was booming in
Silicon Valley and I was like boom i'm
going there and my mom was like you're
crazy you have a great job it's 2009
it's the Great Recession why would you
leave your job to go into industry you
have no connections in and I told her
don't worry mom I got this because this
is bigger than me and I packed my car
not with clothes but a year full of food
supplies because I told her at least I
wouldn't starve as i'm out in my mission
and i literally had a bag of a 30-pound
bag of rice and goya beans and if you're
puerto rican or from the islands you
know Goya is like you live and die by it
and I drove out to Silicon Valley my
first year was an ass seamlessly as I
thought it would be and I did struggle i
had a couch surf and was a little
homeless throughout my first year and
then i applied and got into an mba
program i went to the MBA program in
oakland california at Mills College and
I studied social impact and in this
program I was able to also study
computer science now I never knew I knew
how to code I thought this was something
you know other people did and when I was
in my class I had a professor she was at
MIT she did her MIT masters in I mean
computer science masters in MIT and she
was super badass and she was very
disciplined and I ended up being the
second best in the class which i thought
was like amazing because once again I
didn't know I could do this because I
never had the opportunity to these
education programs and together with my
MBA and with computer science I thought
hey I could create a proposal and I
submitted the proposal to the whole
global case competition where I wanted
to introduce human centered design tech
training courses
two communities that needed it the most
and together really just end poverty now
I didn't win the competition but there
was a elder in the crowd and he was from
India South India and someone I do and
he was like you know I really like your
idea what if I allow you to go to South
India to my school which served the
lowest caste system and launch your
pilot program and that I did I raise
some money and got some donated laptops
and I went to India and in India i
worked with 80 students from
kindergarten to eighth grade and with 20
women and they were teachers and
together we created a program where we
talk computer applications so just
regular microsoft excel different
applications like that and combined it
with their agriculture needs and it was
a pretty dope program around the same
time i met the founder of black girls
code kimberly brian now black girls code
if you haven't heard it's a nonprofit
organization educating young girls of
color black latina narrative in native
american and computer programming their
goal is to have a million girls of color
learn code so they can create and not
just consume tech tools and it was
amazing i went to kimberly no was like
hey your mission is exactly what i want
to do in life can I join your team when
she was like sure I have no money so if
you're willing to do it for free we
could change the world and I was like
badass I'm right with you and from 2011
we worked with 15 girl two years later
we served over 2,000 girls in our
program we were in 10 states around the
United States and johannesburg south
africa and it was amazing as well as it
was challenging because Kimberly was a
single mother and I was in grad school
so not being funded was a real struggle
and we did have meetings with funders
but people often said if we change black
if we took out black from blacker
cold probably then they would donate to
us and we thought know we knew black
girls code was an affirmation it was an
affirmation to the world that black
girls could do so much more than the
opportunities and resources that we were
given at the end of 2013 or in the
middle of 2013 George Zimmerman was
found not guilty for murdering Trayvon
Martin I don't know about you but I felt
like my brother passed away and I felt
there was no justice for him and I felt
very just dad and I was actually
borderline on in depression and I
changed all my social media to black and
I cried for many days and I just felt
this overwhelming pressure that I wasn't
doing enough in the world that unless
Philadelphia to come to Silicon Valley
and still kids like Trayvon Martin
doesn't they don't have the opportunity
to dream they don't have the opportunity
and I wanted to do more so I left black
girls code because I wanted to do more
social justice and technology and in the
winter of 2014 the founders of yes we
coat and keno labs Kings to me they were
like hey we're doing a social justice
hackathon would you like to be a part of
it and at first I kind of like hesitated
like I don't know if I want to but then
they're tagged along their tagline was
what if an app could have saved Trayvon
Martin and I was like your bad ass like
I'm there I'm definitely rolling with
y'all we ended up launching about three
more social justice hackathons and in
July 2014 I remember telling a friend I
even want to go even deeper with this
because I now was aware of government
mass surveillance I was now aware of the
systems that control and oppressed
people of color and I felt technology if
used the right way could really start a
revolution to make the change I wanted
to see
firm was like you know you could get in
jail like you could be arrested for that
right that was like yeah you know I'll
cross that bridge when I get there that
brings me to thought works that works in
case you don't know it's a global IT
consulting firm filled with socially
conscious coders who are passionate
about technology as well as using tech
to solve social problems now I felt this
would be a great opportunity for me to
knowledge share and learn from the best
technologists in the world and then
afterwards go home and work on social
justice projects and thought works
wasn't a stranger to me I've worked with
that works throughout my career and
black girls code yes we code and kino
labs so I was very excited to join the
thought works family and in August 2014
is when I officially joined and did my
first project that weekend I went on
social media as I always do every day I
wake up and I'm like when I open on
social media and my friend sent me this
this picture and it said Ferguson Police
just executed my unarmed son and I felt
like once again there was salt being
added to my wounds and I felt
heartbroken over it but I kept following
the social media of feeds and through
social media I learned who michael brown
was michael brown was unarmed he was 18
and he was going to start college when
Officer former officer Darren Wilson
shot him and murdered him shot him 10
times I learned through social media
that Michael Brown's body lied on the
streets in the middle of a community
apartment complex for four and a half
hours uncovered now this
this happened during a time in America
where people of color black and Latino
we were experiencing so many deaths in
the black and brown community that we
couldn't even go to work filling like
ourselves and in the same summer Eric
Gardner was put in a chokehold and
murdered by NYPD for selling loose
cigarettes untaxed loose cigarettes and
on video you can hear him pleading I
can't breathe I can't breathe and that
summer I couldn't breathe when Michael
Brown died I cannot breathe when Eric
Gardner died I couldn't breathe when
we're clear Boyd died I could not
breathe and as a person of color in
America I had enough according to the
Malcolm X grassroots movement every 28
hours a black person in America is
killed by police officer or vigilante
and according to rosa clemente who is a
a very strong activist in this movement
she says if you add Latinos or
undocumented immigrants this number
might jump to every 14 hours and trust
as a person of color we felt every one
of those hours and i had enough and i
went on social media about created a
facebook post and an email and I blasted
out to every technologist I knew in san
francisco and i said if you are
technologists and if you give a [ __ ]
about black people if you give a [ __ ]
about Latino people about oppressive
people about poor people about
everything we're going through about
Michael Brown I need you to meet me at
thought works office in San Francisco
during the same time that I put my post
out tempo who is the hip-hop music
artist here in st. Louis who has a lot
of influence and always had a lot of
influence online tweet it out on August
ninth basically martial law is taking
place in Ferguson our perimeter
splat coming and going national and
international friends help through a
power of social media this won't be
swept under the rug we are about to
expose Ferguson Police Department we
want answers last post I'm here to tell
you that Ferguson PD is a bunch of liars
from the pit of hell an entire community
saw what really happened and without me
knowing that works actually sent a team
of technologists to Ferguson to help on
the ground now before we start talking
about Ferguson I really want to provide
some context because unlike if you're
anything like me I didn't know where
Ferguson was the media made it seem like
Ferguson was like this small little
place in Missouri like far far away and
no one can get to it and was this
isolated place so I put up this map
because this entire thing is st. Louis
County and Ferguson is st. Louis County
and activists everywhere wanted people
to know Ferguson was not isolated
Ferguson was st. Louis and the cop
culture that was in Ferguson was the
same culture all over st. louis county
and city despite making up of
sixty-seven percent of the population
african-americans accounted for
eighty-five percent of traffic stops
ninety percent of citations and
ninety-three percent of arrest from 2012
to 2014 some examples of the unjust and
harsh arrest of citations include once a
black woman was arrested twice spent six
days in jail and was paid 500 and paid
five hundred and fifty dollars for a
city court all because she parked her
car illegally in 2007 in 2014 she still
owed five hundred and fourteen dollars
another harsh citation was people in
person
had to pay 531 the 531 dollar fine for
having their grass too high that's
pretty unfair according to the date the
Department of Justice report Ferguson
police and court officials were focused
on generating revenue from Ferguson
fines in one quarter they made over
17,000 dollars than any other quarter
now this is the kicker Ferguson is only
one of 92 municipality in st. Louis
County seriously if you're in Ferguson
you cross the street if you're in
another municipality so you're always
being harassed and how Ferguson is set
up is broken up it's very segregated one
part is white one part is black on South
fluorescent with the Ferguson Police
Department that's your white town and
west florissant where Michael Brown was
shot and murdered is your black town and
if you understand that's before going
into the story of Michael Brown then you
can understand why people in st. Louis
demanded answers they were sick and
tired of being harassed and he wanted to
know why was Michael Brown murdered why
did he deserve to die but instead of
providing the people with answers they
used tear gas brought dogs and
militarized police to silence the people
people who had their hands up and was
walking around with signs at most that
they did was block the streets or go to
Ferguson Police Department and demanded
answers the conversation on Twitter
moved from why did Mike Brown deserve to
be deserved to die why was he murdered
too why are we using move to a
militarized police and why are they are
abusing people seeing the community of
Ferguson stand up to the powers that be
in the name of justice and humanity was
breathtaking it was inspiring and
started what is referred to as the
Ferguson uprising
now when thought workers came down and
started working with the people on the
ground in Ferguson they started working
with a non-profit or an organization
clawed hands up United and although
social media was an amazing to to
amplify the message of what was going on
the people of Ferguson needed something
more sustainable to really bring in the
help that they were trying to attract
and together with the direction of
activists on the ground that work
supported activists and built this
website hands up United org and it was a
two to capture blogs to capture the
voices of people on the ground to raise
money for people who were getting
arrested and to help as a total
communication and organizing tool now
hands up United is an organization
created from the Ferguson uprising and
includes Rico death PO dub Tara and Tory
the organization lead strategy on the
ground with field actions and run
several community programs the platform
hands up United was used to for example
to share action details there were over
a hundred actions people posted all over
the world to support Ferguson and Mike
Brown we actually created a tool to
report police brutality not just police
killings because we knew that everyday
citizens went through a lot more police
brutality that was than what was being
reported and we wanted to use this data
to show the misuse of power by the
police what we noticed while creating
this online platform and connecting with
people on social media is that although
Ferguson was a small suburb of st. Louis
the world resonated with it Palestine
Mexico Egypt Brazil Philly Oakland la
New York box more resonated Ferguson
connected the dots and one thing
with this was that people all over the
world was able to see all the
oppressions done on people of color and
on poor people and we were able to see
what it felt like to be oppressed in the
United States now social media was just
one way technology was used in the
movement I wanted to highlight other
ways we use technology in the movement
laptops phones data social media
hashtags live stream donation websites
encryption text email websites and music
now from the end of September through
November saintly was changed what worked
before about amplifying our voice
through social media no longer worked
the technology that we once used to
protect the people by lifting up their
stories were being compromised and
nearly every true that activists use
were being used against them I list this
here and I wanted to just highlight some
examples for phones one of the hands up
United team members had a police officer
put a gun to her head request it and
demanded her phone and the password to
get access into her phone her data was
deleted on social media we had people
who were tweets out accounts and tweet
out what was going on their accounts
were suspended and one time in a couple
of times a hashtags that we would use if
you went to the search engine we're on
social media is and just put search the
hashtag that we were all using you can
even find it so they were being filtered
our live streams that we use to protect
us against police would go online just
publicly automatically and police
officers were using that against us in
court donation websites were hacked our
emails were reviewed and how we knew
that was because Ferguson Police
Department created a letter and shared
it amongst themselves saying that they
review text messages and emails and we
found the letter and you know that's
just one way that the use of tech was
being compromised as we got closer to
the grand jury decisions a hundred FBI
agents were in st. Louis meaning
although we couldn't see and figure out
other ways that the government and the
powers-that-be was using tech against us
we were being surveillance and police
during this time we were becoming
extremely aggressive with targeting
community organizers no longer would you
just go at out at night to protest
against them and be arrested but during
this time right here this is a 19 year
old young lady from lost voices for 45
days she protested and she stood an
encampment to protest michael brown or
darren wilson and one day they caught me
and they're like yo ab is mad police
officers over here we need you to come
and just live stream what's going on so
that's me right there circled with my
camera i was arrested that day for
filming and arrest i got charged by
interfering with police disobeying an
officer and resisting arrest again
police the state and the powers-that-be
were using technology to silence us and
as the cameras disappeared the police
officers they grew more aggressive and
he started targeting lots of community
organizers we desperately needed a shift
from just people tweeting all the time
to actually using technology to help
protect the people on the ground social
media was good at amplifying a message
but as a straight a l'heure author of
the pupils platform taking back power
and culture in the digital age with
state do not be misled by digital
metrics so although you regain a hundred
thousand followers online and although
we had a thousand retweets that didn't
protect the people
and didn't always mean that it helped
with pushing the agenda and what we
wanted in the movement forward Ferguson
allowed and revealed a lot about what
was going on in America it revealed
issues of power privilege race in class
and this is something the technology
community has to struggle with because
right now automation and technology is
impact is impacting every aspect of the
world so these things they affect
everyone here and we're either helping
or hurting the people that it's
affecting entire communities are being
left behind unable to access resources
and opportunities because of systemic
barriers this is what we must work
together to change in November 2014 I
decided I wasn't leaving Ferguson and
although I was supposed to go back to
that works and start another project I
decided that it was a moral decision for
me to stay behind and protect the people
because not only were people being
physically attacked there was the powers
that be that was just um just using
technology to really oppressed them and
I wanted to do something about it so I
decided I will help hands up United
start a tech program so if you can
imagine what would a tech program look
like at the Black Panthers launched one
that's the type of program I wanted to
launch and we wanted to help with this
program we really wanted to help tech
local activists use and understand
technology so they could protect their
people and really just empower them to
continue the movement going so I often
use the term taking the revolution to
the cloud and I launched a crowdfunding
campaign and my goal was to launch ten
thousand dollars in 10 days and if I
could do that I felt confident that I
could really take that money and kind of
leverage it and
the end of 10 days not only did I raise
ten thousand I raise ten thousand
dollars and had organizations like
thoughtworks who donated 30 laptops so
we could start our own computer lab here
in Ferguson Missouri which was amazing
we named the program work a senior
workplace senior is a man who was born
in Ferguson and considered to be the
black Godfather of Silicon Valley as a
teen he too was harassed by Ferguson
Police one day after work it was 510
p.m. he wanted to go to the store and
get some get a soda and ferguson police
pulled him over snatched him up threw
him in the car and drove him to a body
of water he thought they were going to
kill him that day they let him go and
they were like [ __ ] never come back to
Ferguson during this time works a senior
felt a lot of just you know like life
was very hard all he did was be outside
at five ten back then if you were a
black person you could not be outside in
Ferguson past 5 p.m. but he continued
his studies and was amongst the first
black student to go and graduate from
st. Louis University when he graduated
employers told him we don't hire
professional Negroes so he had to get a
job as a teacher that still didn't stop
him he kept learning about more math and
computers and doing a whole bunch of
stuff and so he got an opportunity to go
to California and in that and in
California he was able to create and
work with HP to create their first
laptop so named Rory clay senior is
really an affirmation his name equals
resistance perseverance dedication and
is what we wanted our students to look
up because they could see him he was
from Ferguson he was black he came from
the same struggles that they went
through and they could relate to it so
the logos of the raw replay senior
is to create a workshop that focuses on
particular skill sets so in technical it
was web development graphic design
information security and mobile app
development we want them to focus on
political and social awareness to have a
clear understanding of what is the
digital divide why and how did their
communities are in property and others
aren't just understanding the systemic
barriers that they are going through we
wanted them to understand problem
solving how to use technology to problem
solve and then everything they learned
we wanted them to apply it to the
community and our goal of the program is
to create community driven and socially
aware technologists most of our students
were frontline activists or had a
relative in the movement our first
workshop we focus on web development and
we focus on web development because back
in October students wanted to boycott
large corporations and really uplift and
empower and shrimpton black and brown
businesses they wanted to create a
database of these businesses but these
stores didn't have a web presence so we
thought it would be a perfect
opportunity to combine technology and
really just solve that issue students
learn basic web development languages
open source tools and created websites
for 10 local businesses the program is a
building block for additional programs
because if you can build confidence that
you can use technology and you seen
yourself using technology to solve some
type of issue in your community you will
want to continue learning more in the
fall and winter of this year we will be
launching a javascript and graphic
design workshop students in the workshop
not only leave the program feeling more
empowered they have marketable skill
sets that they can use to get a job and
have a clear understanding on how
technology is impacting their community
to date we graduated 20 students in our
program at the end of the workshop
students receive a five-hundred-dollar
stipend and a laptop to continue their
work they're huge
huge demand for our programs to date we
had over 77 people apply to our program
and to schools in the Ferguson area that
demanded an axe if we could help launch
a tech program in their area the only
reason why we worked with 20 students is
because everything we're doing is
crowdfunding and it costs about two
thousand dollars per student to be in
the program meet Ned Ned as a frontline
activist who has been super excited to
learn about technology ever since I
landed in Ferguson in September he would
ask me a yo AB can you teach me how cold
you can choose me out of quote I'm
trying to build a website Ned has been
arrested three times since August Nights
and he joined our first workshop
graduated and created the website for
Ferguson burger bar if you don't know
Ferguson burger bar definitely go out
and check it during your stay in st.
Louis Ned also received an internship
opportunity to build the website for
Grammy artists india.arie net is
currently a mentor for our other
programs and is heavily involved with
the workplace Senior Program so why is
it important to include tech training in
the movement now besides the fact that
police the government and other powers
are using technology to oppress people
and are using technology to protect
their data and to secure what they're
doing it is important we as a
technologist think about challenging
ourselves be more socially aware and
leverage our resources knowledge and
wisdom to do something bigger for the
people who do not have access to
resources I believe 21st century
activists need 21st century skill sets I
believe now is the time to educate the
people on the ground in neighborhoods
like Ferguson like Philadelphia and in
pressed communities all over the world
on how to create technology not simply
use it now is the time to recognize all
the power we carry in these rooms
because I believe you all have magic
power
and I believe that we together can
collaborate to move the needle forward I
challenge everyone in this room to
really reflect on the impact you're
having on society I know as a
technologist we get caught up in the
term revolutionary who's here heard us
we're creating revolution technology
anyone I believe the term revolutionary
should only be used when we are creating
something for the people for people who
don't have access to for oppressed
people i know we get very hyped on our
inventions and creations but most of the
time we're creating automated and
capitalistic technology is not
revolutionary most of the times we're
creating technology that is creating a
bigger divide in the world a bigger
wealth gap bigger achievement gaps their
opportunity gaps I know there are tons
of online educational materials people
can find and I hear that all the time
when I say hey let's create tech
resources together and people are like
oh we can create this curriculum and put
it on line but let's be realistic fifty
percent of people in the world don't
even have access to the Internet so who
are we creating these tools online for
if we're not creating it for the people
who need it why I put it online and why
can't we just get out of our comfort and
actually go to the communities that need
it and create something solid something
sustainable for them so I'm asking you
to get involved and challenged any
delusions we may have in order to help
people on the ground so what can you do
as a research research how tech is being
used to oppress people research the
systemic barriers research other
organizations connect with organizations
like hands up United connect with
organizations like the dream defenders
these are our two organizations
a lot of work in their community and
they understand the power of technology
and they want to get involved they want
to meet you at that intersection I say
schedule text sessions for local
organizations in your neighborhood go
back to your your company and say let's
have a tech night where we invite
community members to learn the tools
that we know so they could solve
problems in their own communities you
can do stuff like donate to the word
facing your tech program and get in
contact with her terror Thompson who
lives here who's born and raised from
st. Louis and runs the tech program with
hands up United she is a so I definitely
want to thank you thank you so much for
listening to me contact tara contact me
i would definitely be happy to leave
here and know that i inspired someone to
reach out to me so that we can
collaborate and before we leave I wanted
us to do a chance and this chant is
really to inspire us to hone in our
duties and to hold us accountable so I'm
going to read off a line and then your
repeat it cool cool it is our duty to
fight for freedom
it is our duty to win we must love and
protect one another we have nothing to
lose but our chains so I want to do that
one more time because I felt people are
sleeping it is our duty to fight for
freedom
it is our duty to win we must love and
protect one another we have nothing to
lose but our chains thank you
you